they saw a psychopath Kevin here and I
don't care about you at all 10 years of
free educational content that benefits
the world no you're just a view to me
you're a portion of a penny a click that
buys me Doomer fantasy manga and why
would I feel guilty about that berserk
is awesome does it make me a bad person
maybe I don't really care and do you
there's 750 million votes for no you
need psychopath Kevin as much as he
needs you and there we go I just
manipulated your curiosity for 30
seconds so YouTube will officially count
you as a view because that's what a
psychopath would do okay
um I'm not a psychopath uh or even close
really I'll give you my score later but
you just got a glimpse into the
manipulation of a psychopath when we
hear the word psychopath we instantly
think of serial killers and the most
evil criminals in human history and
that's not entirely wrong but the
cardiac surgeon who saves your grandma's
life might actually be more of a
psychopath than John Wayne Gacy I'm
gonna break down what a psychopath is
and isn't with a few examples that'll
show you whether you think like a
psychopath I'll show you the science of
how a psychopath operates why he is what
he is and give you a detailed analysis
of why someone the whole world considers
to be a psychopath actually wasn't then
I'll show you why it's so important that
you turn into a little bit of a
psychopath yourself
first here's how a real psychopath
thinks Dr Kent Keel is one of the
world's leading researchers on
psychopathy he's currently a professor
of psychology neuroscience and law at
the University of New Mexico as he runs
the lab at the Mind research network but
he got his start by interviewing and
analyzing the brain scans of psychopaths
in Canadian prisons including one inmate
he called Bob in his book The psychopath
Whisperer he details one of Bob's
criminal Endeavors hiking over the
border from Canada to the United States
to buy cartons of cigarettes to smuggle
back to resell on taxed pretty standard
low-level crime stuff but what Bob did
to sell his smuggled smokes shows the
difference between Psychopaths and us so
let's consider how a criminal might
unload his Goods the easiest solution
would be to wholesale them to a
middleman and then back guy does the
tedious work of selling each carton it's
not a bad solution you'd make your money
and then you're ready for another trip
over the Border but a psychopath can do
better than that the obvious customer
base for cigarettes is smokers they're
your target market here anyway so you
sell directly to all the smokers that
you can find then rinse and repeat it
makes perfect sense but it wouldn't
occur to a psychopath to do it that way
there's got to be a more lucrative
option like
selling to underage kids they'd have a
hard time getting smokes on their own so
maybe there's a thriving Black Market
waiting to be tapped and this starts to
hint at a psychopath's lack of moral
compass he just wouldn't care that he
was potentially doing harm to kids but
that's still not good enough for a real
psychopath and what Bob actually did
demonstrates the psychopath's total
comfort with serious depravity if it
makes utilitarian sense Bob's preferred
customer was someone who couldn't walk
into a convenience store and buy a pack
or even ask someone else to buy for them
someone who really shouldn't be smoking
someone who would be ashamed to be seen
buying cigarettes at all let alone
actually smoking them someone who would
pay way more money for the product than
anyone else to avoid all those
situations Bob sold his cigarettes to
pregnant women because they paid the
most not only did he never think twice
about the consequences or morals of it
but it was actually pretty proud of
identifying the most vulnerable and most
profitable customers for his smuggled
Goods Bob was a true psychopath but his
callous dispassionate approach and his
total lack of any guilt is only a tiny
portion of what constitutes psychopathy
the word itself is really good and
really useless John seabrook's 2008
article in the New Yorker was titled
suffering souls for a reason that is
literally what the breakdown of the word
psychopath means the awkward marriage of
of the Greek psyche meaning soul and
pathos meaning feeling or suffering it's
a great way to describe something so
complex and it also tells us nothing the
Paradox with psychopathy is that we
barely understand it despite Psychopaths
having always existed every tribe in
human history has had a couple Souls
that just weren't quite right the
conscience that exists for everyone else
that moral code they operate within to
play nice with the rest of society it
just isn't there for them Psychopaths
have a pattern of anti-social behavior
that extends throughout their lives and
Society has to find some way of dealing
with it the book of Deuteronomy is the
fifth book of the Hebrew Torah it was
probably written around 400 BC and
here's how Deuteronomy dealt with an
anti-social kid if someone has a
stubborn and rebellious son who does not
obey his father and mother and will not
listen to them when they discipline him
his father and mother shall take hold of
him and bring him to the elders at the
Gate of his town they shall say to the
elders this son of ours is stubborn and
rebellious he will not obey us he is a
glutton and a drunkard then all the men
of his town are to Stone him to death
you must Purge the evil from among you
all Israel will hear of it and be afraid
yeah
this is one of the earliest if not the
earliest mention of psychopathy
including several elements of the modern
checklist we use to help identify
Psychopaths such as clear patterns of
irresponsible Behavior a history of
juvenile delinquency and a failure to
accept responsibility for one's actions
it reflects how terrifying a psychopath
is to normal people and how much of a
disrupter they can be so so much that
the takeaway was better beat him to
death with rocks a hundred years later
the Greek philosopher theophrastus wrote
characters which outlines 30 different
moral types and their behaviors one was
the unscrupulous man who shamelessly
cheats others and takes advantage of
them part of what clinicians might now
refer to as a parasitic lifestyle from
the Torah to characters we see bad
people but are they actually Psychopaths
maybe but it's really hard to tell who's
a narcissist or selfish or uncaring or
who's just
neurodivergent Hans Asperger himself
initially called Asperger's Syndrome
autistic psychopathy and it's easy to
see why Asperger used the term Alexa
thymia is the inability to identify or
communicate one's own feelings is it
instant definitely obvious whether
someone is Alexa thymic or that they
don't even have feelings to communicate
what about the lack of social emotional
reciprocity that's part of an Autism
Spectrum diagnosis or less nuanced
facial perception how do you separate
someone who isn't very good at it from
someone who isn't programmed to care hey
take these five words and rank them from
most emotionally positive to most
emotionally negative
okay for me the list goes like this it's
totally possible that you rank puppy
first because you love dogs and puppies
bring you a sense of Joy that's even
stronger than laughter that's totally
valid but the rest of the list seems
pretty clear a table is neutral it's
it's just a table you really should not
feel too positive or negative about a
table but the two negative words are
different a parking ticket sucks but
cancer is really bad you wouldn't want
either one but a parking ticket is
clearly preferable real psychopaths
struggle to rank words in this fashion
because to them they're all pretty value
neutral words there's no fine line
between puppy and laughter and even
puppy and cancer whatever they're both
just things who cares to a psychopath it
is what it is the Nuance we see in the
world although little details that
determine who we are how we navigate
life and how we process what's around us
is seriously dampened for a psychopath
but it's like that line in Wayne's World
you know I thought I had Mono once for
an entire year turned out I was just
really bored can you identify where
common problems stop and psychopathy
begins or think about this maybe a
person with a long history of antisocial
behavior is just a big jerk all of that
stuff is part of psychopathy but on its
own it's insufficient to meet our
current threshold of diagnosis as
Humanity very slowly identified the
worst among its own ranks they still had
to figure out what to do about them for
hundreds of thousands of years there was
probably some version of the Deuteronomy
solution just get rid of them if not
attack them physically you shun them
into Exile you eliminate the problem and
negate the danger these people bring to
your tribe's survival the yorubas of
Nigeria called their psychopaths are a
knocking and the Inuit called them
conlangeta psychopathy is not a modern
phenomenon that's a consequence of our
outrageously complicated lives no no
culture has been immune but here's a
question what if we could harness
psychopathy to actually benefit us in
the invention of friends I examined the
concept of dunbar's number
anthropologists and evolutionary
psychologist Robin Dunbar posited that
we have a limited cognitive capacity for
Meaningful social networks but in Kevin
dutton's the wisdom of psychopaths
Dunbar points to a popular early example
of how people made use of the
Psychopaths liabilities Viking
Berserkers these were totally Fearless
Warriors who fought in pure rage their
brutality and savagery differed markedly
not only from the European soldiers who
they encountered but even from other
Vikings they existed on the fringes of
Viking Society they were dangerous so
why Exile your psychos when you can
unleash them on your enemies maybe they
were useful after all we couldn't scan
the brains of Berserkers in 900 A.D but
if we'd subjected them to functional
magnetic resonance imaging fmri we
likely would have encountered a
seriously malfunctioning amygdala the
amygdala is the almond-shaped brain
region that's part of the limbic system
I detailed in My Pain video we describe
it as the fear center of the brain when
you look over the edge at the top of a
building your amygdala goes wild you
know not to lean any further we are
hardwired to process a snake with our
eyes and instantly Sound the Alarm
Danger get away that's the amygdala in
action it is an amplifier of stimuli to
tell you what to do and what not to do
so what happens when your amygdala just
isn't very sensitive Kent keel's early
fmri scans showed clear activity
deficits in the emotional processing
centers of the brain including the
amygdala and the anterior and posterior
cingulate they just weren't very
responsive when we think of psychopaths
as being cool calculated and unemotional
this is one of the reasons why and it
also means you can be an incredible
climber the documentary free solo
profiles Alex Honnold a rock climber who
doesn't use ropes or protective
equipment free solo climbing is being
hundreds or thousands of feet up
mountains using just your hands and feet
it's hard to believe anyone actually
could do this let alone feel comfortable
with it but scans of Alex's brain show
that his fear Center doesn't work like
ours if we're peeing our pants trying
not to fall to our deaths Alex is just
looking for the next Rock to grab onto
is this the same physiological
phenomenon that made Michael Jordan or
David Ortiz such clutch performers in
basketball or baseball are those guys
immune to the pressure with their
amygdalas just drinking a pina colada on
the beach while ours would be exploding
yeah probably and despite possibly
sharing this particular quality with Ted
Bundy none of those athletes are a
psychopath so how does this work you've
got a unique amygdala and at some point
you're at a fork in the road where you
either nail a three at the buzzer or
start burying bodies in your backyard Dr
Benjamin Rush was the preeminent
physician of the early American era and
he was one of the first to recognize
that something really different was
happening here he noticed that injury
and brain damage could actually change
one's Behavior seemingly shifting their
internal moral code in medical inquiries
and observations on diseases of the Mind
Rush describes a Nation he had who
exhibited what we would Now call
psychopathy she was addicted to every
kind of Mischief her wickedness had no
intervals while she was awake except
when she was kept busy in some steady
and difficult employment in these cases
of moral depravity there is probably an
original defective organization in those
parts of the body which are occupied by
the moral faculties of the mind okay so
is psychopathy inherently biological
psychological or both
French physician Philippe penal called
the phenomenon Mani sandelir delirium
without Mania because it encompassed the
behavior of this severely mentally ill
without presenting the obvious outward
behavioral symptoms all the bad behavior
with none of the crazy in 1835 James
Pritchard refined penal's ideas by
describing the condition as a moral
Insanity absent of the impairments or
delusions other patients exhibited it
took a full Century of theories and
research to take the general term
psychopathy from meaning any illness of
the Mind into the focus definition we
use today in 1941 the psychiatrist
hervey cleckley broke through the mask
of Sanity which outlined most of the
characteristics of psychopathy that
we're still using now insincerity lack
of remorse incapacity for love no
realistic Life Plan superficial charm
and a dozen more more a list that goes
Way Beyond Simple sociopathy we'd
finally categorized a Next Level
derangement the kind that defined the
most serious outliers in criminal
society that the mass murderers and the
most unprincipled
immoral monsters
in the decades since we've come to apply
the term psychopath to anyone who has
done something really really bad the
kinds of things no decent person would
seem capable of but are they really all
Psychopaths who actually has a suffering
soul and who is mentally broken in other
ways if we're going to diagnose and
treat the disease or maybe even prevent
it we gotta know the difference here's
an interesting update now we can see it
in the brain neurons in the brain
generate tiny electrical fields that can
be measured by electroencephalograms
eegs when you're hooked up to an EEG and
presented with a stimuli like a picture
of Jaws about to bite you in half you'll
generate a pattern of electrical
responses that can be graphed with Peaks
and valleys the third positive Peak
generated is called the P3 and it
correlates with your brain recognizing
stimuli as being important it's also
basically a psychopath litmus test Kent
Keel conducted research using the
Oddball task a series of tones were
played for subjects and almost all of
them were the same pitch but when a
higher tone was played the Oddball tone
the subject had to press a button as
quickly as they could the results were
incredible out of 81 inmates he tested
97 of those diagnosed with psychopathy
showed an extremely elevated P3 response
zero percent of the non-psychopathic
inmates had an elevated P3 this simple
hearing test was almost perfect as a
diagnostic tool for psychopathy but what
if you don't have an EEG machine handy
and you're hiding from people who want
to kill you how you respond to a really
perverse version of the trolley problem
might give a clue there's one version
where a doctor sees a perfectly healthy
patient with organs that could be
donated to save the lives of five of his
other patients so does he carve up one
completely innocent guy so five others
can live happily ever after and that
one's not too bad I said really perverse
and realistic imagine a family is in the
midst of a horrible brutal Civil War the
atrocities visited upon the Igbo people
of Biafra and the Nigerian conflict of
the late 1960s or Khmer Rouge ravaging
Cambodia in the 70s or the massacres of
Rwandan hutus in the 1990s two parents a
son a daughter and a newborn baby are
all hiding under the floorboards as
soldiers search for them the baby starts
to cry if the family is discovered all
of them will be killed what does the
mother holding the baby do if she's a
psychopath she doesn't even think about
what to do to save most of her family
her baby is just an alarm that needs to
be deactivated in 1884 the RV Dudley and
Steven's trial in England was actually
pretty close to this concept the yacht
minionette wrecked and four men were
stranded at Sea after three weeks of
floating in the middle of nowhere Tom
Dudley and Edwin Stevens killed and ate
a 17 year old crewmate who'd become
severely ill from drinking sea water a
German vessel rescued them and when they
were brought back to England two of them
faced trial for murder and the
non-psychopath Court ruled that
necessity was no legal or moral excuse
for murder they were sentenced to death
which later was altered to A radically
reduced six-month imprisonment which
kind of sends a mixed message here Tom
Dudley regretted nothing and never
accepted the guilty verdict was he a
cold-hearted psychopath worthy of being
put to death or was he a guy in a
terrible situation just trying to stay
alive a century later Jeffrey Dahmer
killed and dismembered 17 men including
drugging them to allow for brain
experimentation that would turn them
into living zombies and engaging in
cannibalism of others during a nearly
18-year period that overlapped much of
Dahmer's activity Theodore Kaczynski
mailed 16 explosive devices almost
indiscriminately leaving three dead and
23 wounded it wouldn't be wrong to
describe either one's Behavior as
Psychopathic but are they both
Psychopaths forensic psychologist Robert
Hare built upon cleckley's psychopathy
rubric to construct the hair psychopathy
checklist which he further revised into
the current pclr a 20 item inventory
conducted through a structured two-hour
interview and a full review of one's
case history each of the 20 items is
scored with a zero one or two depending
on whether behavior is definitely not
somewhat or definitely present the
checklist is meant to be comprehensive
over the course of one's life so if
you've lost your temper a few times
that's not a marker of psychopathy and a
general rule is to score the questions
independently of the big event that got
someone locked up I can't sit down with
Ted or Jeff and run the pclr interview
but I don't really need to because we've
got so many hours of interviews with
them testifying to every facet of their
lives in their own words and testimony
from a range of people close to them
when I'm done evaluating these two
you'll know what a psychopath is and
isn't and maybe you'll know who around
you might be one
this year I finally started exercising
but my potato chip casserole dinner
doesn't mesh with a workout routine
thankfully America's number one
Ready-to-Eat meal kit is delivering
fresh never frozen meals to my door I
really try to reserve my decision-making
energy for making Vsauce 2 videos and
offloading the what delicious healthy
dinner should I make daily decision to
factor is a no-brainer Factor has plans
like calorie smart keto Protein Plus or
Chef's Choice whatever fits your own
personal goals and it's all dietitian
approved so whether you're trying to cut
back on takeout or just want nutritious
meals ready in two minutes without any
prep mess or trips to the grocery store
factor is an unbelievable value and
service so head to factor75.com or click
the link below and use code vsauce250 to
get 50 off your first Factor box thanks
to them for sponsoring vsauce2 that's
factor75.com and code vsauce250 for 50
sent off your first Factor box
number one glib or superficial charm
this describes one's ability to be
likable charismatic and even alluring
pretty useful to entice victims Ted
Kaczynski had very little charm and a
lifelong struggle with interpersonal
relationships Jeffrey Dahmer had enough
Charisma to get his victims and others
to trust him he uh he was very polite I
was somewhat surprised I guess at uh how
cordial Jeff was but he wasn't a master
at interpersonal manipulation throughout
his life and he didn't even have friends
so Ted zero Jeff won somewhat present
number two egocentricity or grandiose
sense of self-worth this can come off as
narcissism or inflated ego a psychopath
is always the smartest guy in the room
and if he fails at something it's never
his fault it's just bad luck Ted
Kaczynski probably he was the smartest
guy in every room he had an IQ of 167
and he constantly ridiculed law
enforcement and the FBI for being stupid
zero Jeff put himself on the same plane
as evil he saw in movies with delusions
of grandeur that even involved Emperor
Palpatine and mimicking his yellow eyes
he really identified with the emperor he
wanted like that mind control he had
those you know yellow eyes so Jeff
actually found some place where he could
get contacts of her yellow eyes Ted 2
Jeff too number three prone to boredom
slash low frustration tolerance boredom
seemed to be a theme for Dahmer and he
sums up how he felt as an 18 year old
out of school living at home and
drinking all day I'm depressed
Ted on the other hand was pretty
satisfied in his cabin living in the
wood want to get a depth in that way of
life there's almost no such thing as
boring and Ted had no trouble completing
degree programs in mathematics first at
Harvard then Masters and doctoral
degrees at the University of Michigan he
was frustrated with pretty much all of
society though and at not being able to
hurt more people frustrating that I
can't seem to make a lethal bomb Jeff's
lifelong pattern of boredom and
frustration is clear Ted's is more of a
mixed bag Ted won Jeff two number four
pathological lying and deception Dahmer
was pulled over by a cop while he had
body parts in a garbage bag in the car
and he very naturally pushed emotional
buttons to convince the policemen that
he was just going to the dump in the
middle of the night the officer asked
what it was he said well it's the
garbage my parents are breaking up and
I'm alone and couldn't sleep so I
thought I'd get rid of the garbage Ted
did engage in deliberate deception to
avoid raising any suspicion from his
neighbors Ted was sly because we would
think he was holed up in his cabin but
he was in Salt Lake he would come back
and stay in the woods until he got all
scruffy again and then we would see him
I think he planned a lot of that Ted
exhibited a clear consistent pattern of
deception as part of his adult
activities but it was focused and
controlled so Ted won Jeff too number
five conning slash lack of sincerity
Dahmer lured many of his victims by
offering them money to pose for his
photography when he intended to drug
them and assault them he would offer
money when they would let armor take
photos of him but he'd say you have to
come to my apartment Ted was less of a
manipulator but he did use his family to
his Advantage I used to send a statement
again Ted's mother would send him money
he would say I've got some chest pain
and they say I should have some tests
but I don't have the money and would in
a sense scam her into sending money
which he would then use to make bombs
Ted won Jeff two number six lack of
remorse or guilt this one is pretty
interesting because Jeff Dahmer had what
clinicians call Insight he knew what
he'd done he knew that it was wrong and
he knew why it was wrong and he felt bad
about it
indecision over whether I should confess
to
her talking about it and analyzing it
shows me just how it worked my thinking
was when someone annoyed Ted he'd do
even Petty things to hurt them and then
celebrate it like when some
motorcyclists made too much noise I
hey there I picked a nice rainy day when
no one would be around I went over again
[Music]
they went in and just destroyed their
cabin and then took a poop in their tub
what yeah poop Justice is not a thing
but Ted also kept a secret coded journal
with his thoughts and he made it pretty
clear that he didn't feel bad about the
big stuff either I'm no longer bothered
by having crippled this guy I laughed at
the idea of having any compunction about
crippling an airline pilot for this one
Ted 2 Jeff zero number seven lack of
effect and emotional depth effect is the
normal range of emotions we both
recognize and feel Psychopaths tend to
be emotionally flat Jeff sums it up
I was capable of a real sense of Love
even back then
not even sure if I am now when a family
member of one of his victims attempted
to attack him physically at his trial he
was cool he kept control I would have
thought he'd jump up he didn't he just
sat there this is Jeffrey Dahmer under
stress and Ted emotions just seemed to
be totally off his radar this is one of
the spots where pretty normal people can
score some points and there's some
Crossover with the autism spectrum where
it's perfectly reasonable that someone
could have a limited capacity for the
complex feelings and emotions that most
people have Ted 2 Jeff 2. number eight
kallus slash lack of empathy empathy is
hard to evaluate because it's so
subjective between individuals and
cultures so how do you evaluate such a
nuanced thing with a serial killer
the normal feelings of uh empathy that
was easier than I thought a psychiatric
assessment agreed his personality
pattern was an individual who uses
people sees them as objects does not
have any empathy my recommendation
really said that this person is too
dangerous to be in the community Ted had
no qualms about injuring or killing
innocent people even the ones who
weren't his intended victims and he also
didn't care about being cruel to his own
brother couldn't wait to tell my big
brother about my ideas but it seemed
like wow he was very dismissive of my
ideas and he said you know Dave real
smart people have a sadistic streak Ted
2 Jeff 2. number nine parasitic
lifestyle Dahmer lived with his father
and then his grandmother for most of his
adulthood he used their houses for
several of his assaults as he worked
low-level jobs only in the last year
before for his arrest did he live on his
own in an apartment Ted really didn't
depend much on anyone else he saved up
enough money to buy land in Montana and
although he occasionally took advantage
of his parents Financial generosity it
probably wasn't enough to get him any
points as a parasite maybe enough for a
one Ted won Jeff two number 10
short-tempered slash poor behavioral
controls though he wasn't often enraged
Jeff ultimately had no ability to
control himself Dahmer took a barbell
from a weight set and hit Stephen Hicks
over the head with it
exactly my head and since I wanted to
stay with them Ted was pretty in control
of himself everything he did was
methodical and he played the long game
rather than giving into flashes of anger
he spent nearly two decades playing a
chess game with the federal government
but he exhibited some really Strange
Behaviors like when he pointed a gun at
a neighbor's child playing in the woods
and I thought it was a mountain lion and
uh so I told her it was time to leave
but it turned out it was Ted he had a
gun on her so yeah it was not like he
was always in control Ted won Jeff two
number 11 history of promiscuity Ted was
pretty much an incel so that's an easy
zero he was concerned about technology
and his theories on its destructive
effects and the ladies did not factor
into that Jeff's life from his teens
onward was tainted by his pair Ophelia
and doing whatever he could to fulfill
his desires
zero Jeff two number 12 history of early
behavioral problems Psychopaths tend to
have prominent behavioral issues from an
early age from physical assaults to
theft to the sadistic emotional and
psychological treatment of others Ted's
brother described him as detached which
his mother blamed on the mysterious
treatments given to him during a
hospitalization in his infancy but
otherwise just a little weird Jeff's
interest in animal parts probably went
into unnatural territory and even in his
teens he was conspiring to victimize
people and not just thinking about it he
saw it off a bat for a weapon to knock
the man unconsciously he had hid behind
a tree the jogger he was targeting
didn't run by that day but it
demonstrates how early Jeff was engaging
in seriously anti-social Behavior Ted
zero Jeff two number 13 lack of
realistic long-term plans Ted enrolled
at Harvard when he was only 16 then went
to Michigan and then was a professor at
UC Berkeley as he saved money to move to
Montana where he then engaged in a
carefully planned 18-year campaign of
wreaking havoc now most of Ted's Life
Plan wasn't good but he was realistic
and did exactly what he set out to do
Jeff drank for a while then did a few
months at Ohio State and dropped out
then went into the army and got kicked
out and then worked his night shift
Chocolate Factory job in between getting
booked for acts of public lewdness
assault of a minor and yeah uh no real
life plan there Ted zero Jeff two number
14 impulsivity Ted Kaczynski spent most
of his time thinking before he acted the
total opposite of impulsivity and that
total opposite of Jeff my thoughts
obviously weren't the thoughts of the
same person at the time I would have
rather be stayed alive but strangling
seemed to be the way to keep him Ted
zero Jeff two number 15 irresponsible
Behavior Ted didn't really engage in the
sorts of everyday behaviors we'd call
irresponsible not not like Jeff's
habitual drunkenness which landed him
his army discharge his father and Sherry
is soon to be stepmother came back to
the house there wasn't much food in the
refrigerator alcohol bottles were around
it looked like a life that was in
trouble Ted zero Jeff two number 16
frequent marital relationships yeah no
so this is a quality of many Psychopaths
a Perpetual cycle of serious
relationships and often having kids they
end up distant from or completely
detached from Ted didn't have any
romantic relation relationships to speak
of Jeff had one Tony Hughes who he ended
up killing but to give you an example of
how bad Ted wasn't wooing the ladies he
sent three letters to a waitress one
inviting her to be his Squall in Canada
a second one with a resume of his
academic credentials and a third one
kinda shaming her for not being
interested in dating him Ted earned his
zero Ted zero Jeff zero number 17
history of juvenile delinquency formal
contact with the juvenile Criminal
Justice System wasn't part of either
man's childhoods neither child was
normal but there wasn't an obvious
pattern of criminal behavior that would
have tipped off anyone even their own
families this one is really tricky with
Jeff he probably gets a point here for
going way past normal scientific
curiosity with his Taxidermy and which
was glossed over because he hid it so
well and the family's shed and because
it wasn't really obvious how to get him
professional help back then he became
interested in the internal organs
obviously
kids slicing up animals is now
considered a well-known red flag Ted
zero Jeff won number 18 revocation of
conditional release Ted was never
charged or arrested with a crime before
the FBI finally identified him as the
Unabomber and hauled him in but Jeff was
a known quantity to Milwaukee Police in
the 1980s as a series of senses like
public indecency lewdness and
inappropriate contact with minors he
kept offending even after getting slaps
on the wrist and his offenses actually
got more frequent and more severe Ted
zero Jeff too number 19 failure to
accept responsibility for own actions
Ted accepted responsibility for his
actions and Justified them as the
necessary execution of his political
philosophy he knew what he was doing and
he accepted those consequences so much
that he refused to let his lawyers enter
an insanity plea as he thought it would
undermine his arguments Jeff less so he
indicated that he was sort of a passive
vessel for his actions
he knew what he did was wrong but he
didn't feel like he was the one doing it
and this is a really tough gray area
because it's nearly impossible to sort
out his exact level of culpability he
had already confessed so I knew Dahmer
didn't have a defense so I said to him
what do you want me to do he said I want
to know who I am what I am Ted zero Jeff
one
finally number 20 many types of offenses
Ted engaged in one type of offense over
and over he had ideation of others as a
younger man but Psychopaths tend to do
damage in a lot of different areas they
hurt people physically they steal they
engage in fraud the pclr gives a score
of two when there are six or more types
of offenses present Jeff's criminal
Behavior was much more varied than tez
and evolved a range of different
offenses by now you know all the details
here enough to know his score Ted zero
Jeff two
okay when we add up the totals from all
20 inventory items Jeffrey Dahmer scores
a 33. the minimum score for psychopathy
is 30 so he qualifies this is not very
surprising but it should be because some
people get perfect scores of 40. that
means there are psychopaths who check
even more boxes on the pclr and some
more severely than Jeffrey Dahmer the
guy who cooked and ate a whole bunch of
Milwaukee wasn't even a peak psychopath
conversely the man who waged a
two-decade war against airline
Executives scientists and anyone around
them all throughout the United States he
scores a 13. he wasn't even close to
being a psychopath but something was
clearly very wrong his actual diagnoses
are disputed one psychiatrist who
examined him diagnosed him with paranoid
schizophrenia while a forensic
psychiatrist suggested he had a
schizotypal personality disorder
whatever psychiatric disorders Ted
Kaczynski suffered from it wasn't
psychopathy by the way the average North
American male scores about a four on the
pclr it's pretty normal to have a few
quirks or negative qualities I had an
independent analysis done to get my own
score I got a two which is two more than
zero
so obviously we got a sense of Jeffrey
Dahmer's psychopathy a little too late
but what are the options when a
psychiatrist diagnosis psychopathy is
there any way to treat it first of all
think about what Psychotherapy is the
patient is the center of a doctor's
attention with a captive audience solely
concerned with whatever the patient says
that is a fantastic scenario for the
psychopath those situations are exactly
what he feeds off of and yeah it's
usually a he female Psychopaths occur
about 10 percent as often as males do
and how can the therapist be sure the
patient is telling the truth when he's
likely to be a pathological liar it's
extremely delicate if therapy isn't done
right it can make a psychopath worse
the best approach is to identify
Psychopathic behavior in Youth and
intervene early that's possible with a
modified youth checklist for the pclr
like kids in high school tend not to
have frequent marital relationships and
the Mendota juvenile Treatment Center in
Wisconsin has made serious progress with
high scores they use a decompression
treatment model named after the gradual
transition of divers Rising back to the
surface and it slowly pulls them out of
the strictest incarceration like
solitary confinement and into the normal
general population as they go through a
host of tailored mental health
interventions and cognitive behavioral
therapies it seems to work serious
violent offenders reduced recidivism by
half and the overall group was less
likely to engage in violent felonies and
even the kids who did reoffend were out
longer before they did a cost-benefit
analysis and the Journal of research in
crime and delinquency showed that for
every dollar Wisconsin spent on njtc's
interventions the state saved seven
bucks but what if we don't want to treat
psychopathy at all that doesn't sound
like a serious question but it's a very
real argument in the wisdom of
psychopaths Kevin Dutton quotes one of
the UK's top neurosurgeons I have no
compassion For Those whom I operate on
that is a luxury that I simply cannot
afford in the theater I am reborn as a
cold heartless machine totally at one
with the scalpel drill and saw when
you're cutting loose and cheating death
high above the snow line of the brain
feelings aren't fit for purpose emotion
is an entropy and seriously bad for
business I've hunted it down to
Extinction over the years it's like Alec
Baldwin the surgeon in Malice saying you
ask me if I have a God complex let me
tell you something
I am God that's admittedly an extreme
example but do you want your heart
surgeon to be emotionless and cold as he
cuts you open or do you want them to
worry that if they screw up they'll turn
your kids into orphans sweaty shaky
hands and scalpels are a bad combination
Dutton argues in his book that some
qualities of psychopaths are actually
extremely desirable he calls them the
seven deadly winds think about this in
the context of the Psychopaths I've
talked about like cigarette Smuggler Bob
and Jeffrey Dahmer ruthlessness how many
times have you not gotten what you've
wanted or even what you've needed
because you didn't fight strongly enough
for yourself you gotta do what you gotta
do would you prefer a political leader
who gets bullied or one who ruthlessly
advocates for your best interest charm
charm is great when people like you
everyone gets along and it's easier to
persuade them in a study ranking
professions of the highest scores on the
psychopathy index salespeople were
number four and journalists were number
six where are those careers without the
same kind of charm that Ted Bundy used
to impress dozens of women
focus focus is really interesting
Stanley Rockman researched the heart
rates of decorated bomb disposal
operators while they were in the field
when the very best operators entered a
state of danger their heart rates didn't
just remain stable they went down they
were so focused on the task and so
unaffected by the danger that they were
actually relaxed what would your life be
like if the things that should stress
you out actually calmed you instead
mental toughness a psychopath does not
feel anxiety there's just nothing to be
anxious about they're incredibly
resilient including not being bothered
by imprisonment to them it's just
whatever where would you be if nothing
ever got to you fearlessness do you want
to be fearless or a better question are
there people around you who really
should be here's an example if you live
in Uvalde and your kids sitting in
chemistry when you get the phone call of
your nightmares do you want the police
officers outside to have the
fearlessness of a psychopath or be too
scared to save your daughter mindfulness
imagine always being cool calm and
collected having a permanent sense of
mental Clarity free of any interference
from negative or irrational thoughts
just you present all the time with the
mindfulness of a Buddhist monk action
CEOs and lawyers rank number one and
number two on that list of Psychopathic
professions because taking action
matters to their success they're
decisive they're confident they don't
second guess themselves if you had to
hire someone to to run your company
would you want them to be like Steve
Jobs or the really nice old lady at your
local library sorry Myrtle the trick
with all of these qualities dutton's
Seven Deadly winds is to be able to
control them it's deploying them
strategically so you're ruthless at the
negotiating table but not at the dinner
table it's having a knob on each one
where you can dial it up or down
depending on the needs of the situation
and never cranking it up to 11 beyond
your control because we know those same
cops that you want to be Fearless can
overdo that with catastrophic results
you want to keep an open mind but not so
open that your brain falls out and you
do want to be charming and charismatic
but not to the point where you're faking
it and people start thinking you're a
snake if you handle each of these
qualities right you've got super powers
and if you don't you'll be sitting in a
Cell in a super max
this is the terrifying beauty of
psychopathy it's our brain's most
dangerous game and there's so little
room for error maybe it's so dangerous
that you don't even want to play it
maybe you don't want anyone else to play
it either if we can identify psychopathy
and somehow cure it a tremendous
proportion of the world's most serious
problems would go away
instantly murders violence fraud about
four out of every five psychopaths in
the United States are in prison because
their behaviors put them there
psychopathy is tied to some of the most
destructive heinous behaviors in society
and wouldn't preventing serial killers
or domestic abuse be incredibly useful
let's say we hit a point where an fmri
scan takes 30 seconds and is cost
effective enough to be part of your
annual physical if your doctor could
screen everybody for psychopathy then
what should someone with a pclr score
above say 20 be obligated to disclose
that to their neighbors employers and
domestic partners for everyone's safety
or is that a violation of their
individual rights and effectively making
them pay for crime they haven't even
committed yet should gun owners have to
pass a pclr and should brain surgeons
have to fail it what's the level of
culpability for a criminal who is a
clinically suffering Soul how
responsible is he for the Terrible
Things he's done when his amygdala
couldn't terrify him he isn't programmed
to feel any guilt and his entire world
is a utilitarian calculation of value if
we could identify genetic markers for
psychopathy in the womb should the
pregnancy be terminated it could spare
us from serial killers and it could also
wipe out a generation of Visionaries
eighty percent are already locked up but
that other 20 that remain have found a
way to be integrated into society
they're the lawyer who successfully
defends a grieving mother from a
homicide charge when the problem was
actually sudden infant death syndrome
they're the firemen who ran into your
neighbor's burning house and dragged his
kids out safely Through the flames they
make the UFC amazing entertainment and
they helped give you the phone or
computer you're watching this video on
their our Berserkers
when James Fallon was studying brain
scans to identify Psychopathic Behavior
he found one that had several clear
markers of psychopathy when he looked up
the scans reference number he discovered
the scan he was reading the one with
Clear Proof of psychopathy
was his they take the incredible risks
none of us are willing to take because
it simply doesn't bother them if they
fail they're the nurse whose heart rate
goes down when you're rushed into the ER
after a car accident
been to space and the next ones will be
on Mars because normal people don't have
the temperament for those kinds of
greatness we need the world's most
dangerous people to push their aberrant
qualities to the brink of psychopathy
and then barely catch themselves before
falling off the edge the most
outrageously destructive psychopaths are
household names and they get lurid
documentaries on Netflix but about one
percent of people are clinically
psychopathic
is about 80 million Psychopaths
worldwide
and it means that about 45
000 of this channel subscribers are
psychopaths how many of you are hiding
in plain sight walking around wearing
your mask of sanity
tiptoeing the tightrope
of super villain
or superhero
and how many of us
would ever even know
and as always thanks for watching like I
would love nothing more than to kill
somebody nothing more to make me super
happy I would own that too I don't know
if it may be liable I might have to say
I'm sorry if the cops came but own it
man be a psychopath it's fun see you
later
[Music]